avec nous le ministre de la Santé grosse
journée pour Monsieur Dubé monsieur Dubé
bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur roi votre
projet de loi vous l'avez montré là vous
avez dit les gens ont eu peur quand je
suis arrivé dans la pièce assez épais
comme ça
ça prenait un gros projet de loi pour ce
que vous voulez faire à ce point-là
je peux vous dire que c'est pas mon
objectif de passer des heures et des
heures en commission parlementaire pour
faire des articles de loi par contre on
a pas lésiné pour faire tous les
changements que les Québécois sont en
droit de s'attendre et s'il faut passer
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines en
commission parlementaire je vais le
faire parce que pense qu'on doit au
Québécois alors oui c'est très costaud
mais
réformer le réseau de santé c'est
important puis je peux il faut le faire
et vous le savez mieux que moi vous êtes
pas le premier qui veut réformer le
réseau de la santé on vous a préparé un
petit condensé c'est quelques secondes
écoutez ça ça vaut la peine non non mais
c'est intéressant c'est depuis Robert
Bourassa on écoute
qui ne sont pas négociables c'est
d'avoir une médecine civilisée au Québec
est-ce que c'est le même atteint que le
médecin coordonnateur est l'urgence et à
l'émission va être là je pense qu'il
faut quand même laisser aux mesures le
temps de se mettre en place encourager
de plus en plus les médecins à faire du
domicile allez voir la personne la
transformation technique à faire là
éclaire depuis longtemps là on va devoir
la faire parce qu'on peut plus permettre
de gaspiller notre argent faut qu'on ait
des solutions qui vont faire en sorte
qu'on reconnaisse la lourdeur des
clientèles que la rémunération du
personnel nous sommes toutes et tous un
peu prisonniers de ce préjugé tenace qui
veut que toutes les urgences du Québec
soient problématiques si on veut baisser
cette attente là l'urgence il faut se
faire sortir les patients qui prennent
des lits qui ne devraient pas
comprenez que les gens se disent bien
sûr que la volonté là à chaque fois mais
pourquoi lui il réussirait
mais écoutez je pense qu'on a
l'opportunité avec la pandémie qu'on
vient de vivre ensemble trois ans de
pandémie de se rendre compte qu'on a pas
le choix de statu quo il est pas
acceptable quand on fait la gestion de
changement que j'ai eu la chance de
faire dans d'autres organisations mais
il faut qu'il y a un consensus du public
ou des gens qui sont impliqués de dire
il faut changer on a cette chance là
aujourd'hui que tous les Québécois sont
d'accord de statu quo il est pas
possible ça c'est la première chose
deuxièmement quand on a déposé notre
plante santé et un an on n'a pas fait ça
du revers de la main on a travaillé on a
eu un consensus sur le plan sur la
vision et non le prix un an pour déposer
le projet de loi qu'on dépose
aujourd'hui et pendant cette année-là je
pensais ça qui est encouragé les
Québécois c'est qu'on a commencé à avoir
des succès des succès comme par exemple
les ovnis à qui on avait demandé de nos
médecins de famille pardon à qui on a
demandé de faire une prise en charge
puis savez-vous quoi battu l'objectif
alors si on est capable d'accumuler des
petits succès pendant qu'on met au fur
et à mesure les pièces du casse-tête je
pense que les gens vont y croire puis
c'est comme ça que ça se garantit du
changement de gestion de changement en
ayant des succès je vais aller dans plus
de détails mais il y a une autre
question qui est peut-être fondamentale
que je veux vous poser parce que vous
auriez pu me répondre aussi monsieur Roy
moi la différence c'est que j'ai l'appui
de mon premier ministre pour aller au
bout de cette réforme là parce qu'on a
vu monsieur Rochon dans les archives on
en a vu d'autres qui quand ça commençait
à brasser soit avec les médecins soit
avec les syndicats soit avec la
population hop il y a eu des petits
reculs monsieur barrette le dit aussi
dans son cas mais bon est-ce que vous
vous avez est-ce que Monsieur Lego vous
a regardé en disant Christian jouait
avec toi du début à la fin puis il faut
vraiment foncer dans cette réforme là
oui ça c'est sûr que c'est une des
conditions gagnantes c'est d'avoir
l'appui du gouvernement monsieur Legault
et moi on en parle de ça depuis des
années
[Musique]
travail déjà très fort mais de mieux
travailler ensemble et ça pour ça faut
s'entendre sur certains principes par
exemple la responsabilité d'une région
c'est pas on ne demande pas aussi
spécialiste de se concentrer uniquement
sur l'hôpital mais de dire vous avez
aussi la responsabilité d'une région on
appelle ça la responsabilité populaire
et ça ça va nous permettre d'améliorer
les temps d'attente à nos urgences
au médecin spécialiste est-ce que vous
demandez de travailler plus d'heures non
pas nécessairement monsieur ou est-ce
que je veux dire c'est que j'ai des
spécialistes qui travaillent déjà très
forts mais dans certaines spécialités
dans certaines spécialités ce que je
demande au docteur Oliva qui est
responsable c'est de dire comment c'est
spécialités là doivent mieux travailler
par exemple avec les hommes ni c'est pas
normal
en ce moment 800 000 rendez-vous en
attente entre les ovnis et les
spécialistes alors c'est pas
nécessairement travailler plus fort mais
comment la collaboration entre les deux
peut être plus efficace je me suis coupé
mais j'essaie une prise en charge plus
large des médecins spécialistes avec le
patient là que ça soit pas juste l'omnie
qui soit que la porte d'entrée qui a une
prise en charge plus large exactement
puis regardez l'année passée
il y a regardé ce qu'on a fait avec les
ovnis l'an dernier quand on a demandé
500 000 prises en charge supplémentaires
on a aussi permis que ça soit faite par
un autre professionnel de la santé donc
il y a d'autres membres que contribué
alors moi ce que je dis c'est entendre
en nous sur le principe c'est ça qui est
dans le projet de loi qui doit y avoir
une responsabilité des spécialistes
aussi d'une région d'un établissement
mais c'est ça j'essaie de comprendre par
rapport à aujourd'hui parce que vous
dites puis on l'a vu là vous fait
tellement attention monsieur Dubé pour
pas faire de la peine à personne pour
pas avoir l'air de Monsieur Barret
justement qui arrivait avec son
bulldozeu vous êtes très très vous êtes
dans la gentillesse
ultime vous dites tout le monde est
gentil tout le monde veut bien mais pas
toujours d'accord avec ça mais pour un
médecin spécialiste lui dire vous allez
prendre en charge de façon plus globale
une région ça doit vouloir dire plus
d'heures
je vais être très clair parce que je
passe je l'ai dit au docteur Oliva puis
je l'explique à la population je vois un
petit peu plus loin ce que j'ai dit pour
les spécialistes exactement ce qu'on a
avec les amis les amis on se capte pas
des activités médicales prescrites OK
ça ça veut dire que non seulement vous
pratiquez comme
omni mais on vous demande dans certaines
régions quand on vous alloune une région
de faire d'autres activités comme d'être
à l'urgence comme par exemple d'être
dans un CHSLD ou de faire du soin à
domicile vous me suivez mais c'est
exactement ce qu'on va demander aux
spécial on va dire votre travail à
l'hôpital vous le faites très bien vous
le faites très bien dans vos spécialités
mais dans la population des fois il
manque des rendez-vous dans des
cliniques il manque des rendez-vous
venez nous aider et peut-être que le
temps à l'hôpital pourrait être faite
par d'autres personnes alors c'est là
que cette collaboration là puis je veux
vous dire
Monsieur puis là on n'est pas en train
de déprécier les médecins spécialistes
bien beau mais vous dites quand même ils
devront pour que ça marche pour que les
gens voient des changements c'est ça
votre but que les médecins spécialistes
mettent l'épaule à la roue donc il y a
négociation qui commence qui peut être
difficile mais regardez premièrement
c'était de mettre tout ça sur la table
clairement c'est ça moi j'appelle ça ma
base de discussion quand je dépose un
projet de loi comme je l'ai fait avec
les hommes ni l'an dernier on parle de
là bon on peut avoir les réactions
publiques qu'on attend c'est correct
c'est normal maintenant est-ce qu'on
garde le canal de communication entre
nous pendant qu'on négocie pour qu'on
fasse comme avec les hommes ni l'an
dernier arrivé à une solution que tous
les Québécois ont bénéficié c'est-à-dire
plus de prise en charge est-ce que je
vais vous montrer des chiffres que vous
connaissez mieux que moi sur le temps
d'attente pour les urgences le sucre
attendre plus qu'un an on est rendu à
18000 ça a baissé des chirurgies ça
baissait un peu il y a peut-être
quelques mois c'est peut-être à 19 20 en
tout cas monter jusqu'à 23000 ça baisse
pas vite cela à quel moment
l'agence qui va s'installer les
spécialistes qui ont un rôle à plongeon
élargi à quel moment on va voir si les
diminuer
j'espère qu'on n'a pas besoin d'attendre
l'agence parce que ce que je vous dis ça
peut se faire par négociation pour
certains éléments mais si dans certains
cas ou dans certaines spécialités le
principe n'est pas accepté ça va aller
moins vite alors c'est un petit peu je
vous dis oui c'est vrai que le projet de
loi il est costaud mais il faut
continuer moi j'ai un entame avec les
médecins qui doit être signé pour les
trois prochaines années est-ce que tout
doit être dans le projet de loi où il y
a des choses qu'on peut mettre dans
l'entente les gens ce que les gens
veulent savoir Monsieur Dubé parce que
vous-même vous l'avez très bien dit cet
après-midi le stade depuis tout à
l'heure le statu quo n'est pas
acceptable quelqu'un que Dieu allait au
privé pour faire remplacer sa hanche
parce que c'est il y avait trois ans
d'attente à quel moment au Québec on va
être capable de régler ça c'est un peu
ça que les gens ont en tête moi ce que
poésie c'est que dans certaines
spécialités ça va se faire plus
rapidement je vous donne un exemple
c'est plus facile de faire faire des
cataracques dans les cliniques privées
en attendant d'avoir le personnel notre
plus gros problème c'est pas les
médecins spécialistes c'est notre
personnel qui nous manque nos
infirmières mais ce que je vous dirais
moi j'ai dit un horizon de 2025 c'est là
qu'on va voir mais d'ici ce temps-là
comme vous l'avez vu on est passé de
23000 à 18000 attendent de plus qu'un an
moi je souhaite qu'on voit les
modifications tous les jours mais les
leviers dont on parle les leviers dont
on parlait tout à l'heure moi je pense
que plus vite on va les avoir puis c'est
pour ça que j'ai besoin de l'opposition
pour être capable de mieux travailler le
projet de loi et le dépôt non seulement
le déposer mais de le faire voter le
plus rapidement une éternité à chaque
paragraphe nécessairement et voilà
les syndicats là j'ai parlé beaucoup des
médecins spécialistes quand même un
morceau important l'agence on comprend
que va gérer il y aura un employeur au
Québec plutôt que 34 ou 39 ou 38 34 un
employeur qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour moi pour nous là qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire des infirmières
qui pourront se promener ça veut dire
qu'est-ce que ça change qu'est-ce que
c'est quoi l'avantage de ça il y en a
plusieurs mais je vous avais commencé
pensons à l'infirmière ou à des
professionnels une des choses que qui
est absolument importante pour une
infirmière qui travaille dans le réseau
c'est son ancienneté son ancienneté elle
est là depuis 10 ans 15 ans on a vu des
situations aberrantes ou une infirmière
qui travaille par exemple à Montréal
après un certain nombre d'années 20 ans
veut aller peut-être pratiquer dans les
Laurentides parce que la famille a
changé etc mais en ce moment parce que
j'ai 35 employeurs cet ancienneté là
n'est pas transférable la journée que on
a un employeur des cloisons
plus c'est vrai
qui va aller à Saint-Girons le 6 de
Saint-Jérôme ne reconnaîtra pas son
ancienneté alors que David d'avoir des
infirmières mais oui en ce moment il y a
énormément de restrictions sur une base
volontaire dont on parle pas de mobilité
de forcer un employé un employé alors
donc ça a pas de bon sens que ça soit
quand même
très après-midi en donnant cet
après-midi en donnant des exemples donc
mais en parallèle avec ce que Madame Le
Bel fait très bien la négociation je
veux être capable de dire cette on
appelle ça une une ancienneté réseau ça
fait longtemps que c'est demandé par les
infirmières mais il faut être capable de
discuter avec les syndicats que oui un
employeur unique va permettre ça mais on
peut tout le faire plus rapidement aussi
avec la négociation collective ok
monsieur Dubé je parlais de Monsieur
Barret tout à l'heure le côté boldozer
je pense qu'il serait d'accord même avec
nous lui applaudit ce que vous êtes en
train de faire l'agence les dis ça se
fait des années qu'on aurait dû faire ça
mais lui fonctionnait carotte bâton puis
monsieur Couillard lui a demandé lui
enlever le bâton puisse pour ça que j'ai
pas pu continuer là c'est bien comme je
soulignais tout à l'heure vous avez eu
un ton très positif puis vous voulez
dans une grande organisation inspirée
puis c'est tout va bien mais est-ce
qu'il va avoir est-ce que vous allez
devoir forcer sa fonctionne pas
allez-vous avoir le courage de politique
de nous affronter au médecin s'ils
veulent pas ou à d'autres groupes au
syndicat
tout à fait mais on n'est pas rendu là
je vous dis c'est très clair on va
demander sensiblement ce qu'on demande
déjà aux ovnis aux spécialistes comment
on va y arriver mais ça va être exigeant
ce qu'on fait probablement pas pour la
grande majorité des médecins je le
répète parce qu'ils font déjà
alors
il y a des demandes très claires et on
va être ferme sur ces demandes Christian
Dubé on va suivre ça parce que les
Québécois vont veulent puis vous l'avez
bien résumé que les choses s'améliorent
il y a des choses qui ont pas de bon
sens encore en 2023 d'attendre d'Axel
c'est le fameux accès quand les gens
entrent sont contents vous l'avez
souligné aussi mais bon dieu que c'est
compliqué à entrer parfois n'est-ce pas
et voilà il faut ouvrir la porte un peu
plus grande Christian Dubé ministre de
la Santé merci à la prochaine au plaisir
Monsieur Merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI